Let's look at the answer to our lock variable quiz.
In this code we are using the lock, CountLock and it's
an array of lock that has elements. So we are
indexing into the array and getting that one element of the
array and that's our lock that we lock to access
count of L. And then we unlock that lock. So the
question was, what is really this lock? Is it just another
location in shared memory? So, CountLock of L really is just
a memory word. Or is it a location in
some sort of special synchronization memory? So, there is
a sort of special memory where this array of
locks is residing. Or is it that locks are special
variables that we can refer to like this in
code, but really they don't have memory addresses whatsoever?
The correct answer here is that a lock is
just another location in shared memory. So, a lock is
a variable just like any other variable. It has a memory address.
We can load to get its value, we can store to change its
value and so on. So, now we will see what that variable looks
like and what the lock and unlock functions are supposed to look like.